Speaker 1: I want to start today sort
of by talking a little bit about 20,
22 and the midterms, we've been saying we don't
yet really know how strong the challenges will
be against these various Trumpy and members
of Congress, Marjorie Taylor, Greenlawn,
Bobert Madison, Cawthorn, and then, you know,
folks like Matt Gates and many others. There's
no shortage of a lot of folks who need to be
seriously challenged and hopefully removed.
There is a very interesting new ad from Madison
Catherines opponent basically framing Madison
Cawthorn as the type of person that would end
up being radicalized into a domestic terrorist,
almost kind of framing Madison. Cawthorn does the
ad as like a Timothy McVeigh type. And, you know,
we've talked about Madison Cawthorn before. He's
a guy who remember, he had this controversy where
he vacationed at like Hitler's vacation home or
like did tourism at Hitler's vacation home and
seemed sort of like relish. She seemed to relish
being in where there was what he called supreme
evil. But there was something like a little bit
fanboy ish about it. It was all really weird.
He sort of alluded to bringing guns on the House
floor. He got caught trying to bring a gun on his
carry on luggage onto a plane, says he didn't
know it was there, then brought a knife to a
school board meeting last week in North Carolina.
You know, just that really a guy who's really
a problematic radical, who has made it clear
he's not about policy at all. He's just about
Meems and PR and communication and tweeting
in this type of thing. Check out this ad
we're going to look at. So there's a great
article about this race on LGBTQ nation,
which says Madison Cawthorn has become one
of the loudest and most extreme voices in
the modern Republican Party. Now, his
Democratic opponent, a lesbian minister,
is pointing out what has happened in front of
voters eyes. The congressman, like many young men,
has been radicalized by extremists and fits the
stereotype now for a would be domestic terrorist.
Jasmine Beach, Ferrare tweeted with a copy of the
ad, quote, Like too many young people before him
from around the world to write right next door,
Madison Cawthorn exhibits the signs of a young
man who has been radicalized by extremists
and is now dangerously radicalizing others
in the short spot beach. Ferrare notes that
Cawthorn started out claiming he was interested
in unity and bipartisanship before switching
to violent rhetoric and urging insurrection.
Let's take a look at the ad, because this
is a very interesting approach to one,
maybe one way to deal with some of these
Trumpy and extremists that fundamentally
are very anti-American in terms of the
values they bring forward. But they're
framed as being very patriotic. Let's take a look.
Speaker 2: Like too many young people before him,
from around the world to right next door,
Madison Hawthorne exhibits the signs of a
young man who has been radicalized by extremists
and is now dangerously radicalizing others.
In six months, Madison Corcoran went from
Speaker 3: this where someone who can really help
ease this partizan divide in our country right
Speaker 2: now to stoking insurrection. Wow,
this crowd has some fight in
it. And now eight months later,
he calls these violent insurrectionists political
hostages and can't let go of the big lie.
Speaker 3: I guess, you know, in our election
systems continue to be rigged to be stolen.
It's going to lead to one place. Bloodshed.
Speaker 2: Republican Congressman Madison
Cawthorn warning of, quote, bloodshed, again,
justifying potential violence. I'm Jasmine
Beechboro. As a mom, an ordained minister and a
county commissioner, I'm running to defeat Madison
Hawthorne, not by confronting hate with more
hate, but with love of neighbor, love of community
and love of country, because violent extremism has
no place in western North Carolina. This isn't who
we are. And we need to be crystal clear about
the difference between right and wrong. Madison
Hawthorne is a danger to our democracy. I'm asking
for your help not just to defeat him, but to come
together to create the America our kids deserve.
Speaker 1: Yeah,
so, you know, I think, unfortunately,
because this authoritarian slide
has happened over time and this departure from
norms and the way we used to talk about political
issues, it all it corson's slowly, as we've talked
about when Donald Trump won in November of 2016,
we had a bad feeling about what was
going to happen. But if I had told you
that day what 20/20 would look like under Donald
Trump, all of the insanity and all of the people
that would be elected in twenty, eighteen
and twenty twenty in that Trump be in vain,
it wouldn't have seemed believable to most people,
but it happened slowly over time. And then now all
of a sudden, what really are radical extremists?
And if their religion was a different one, we
would be calling these people probably terrorists.
There would be the right would certainly be
calling them terrorists. There's no doubt about
it. But because they're ostensibly Christian
and because they're Republicans and because
they subscribe or appeal to this very myopic
sense of what it means to be for America,
they've gotten a pass thanks to the slow
slide towards radicalization that has taken
place. But what this ad does a really good job of
is showing put it all together, you know,
tourism in the house of the Führer, these
outrageous videos that have like a Columbine
shooter vibe of him punching and punching and
punching a tree as some kind of training that
he's doing and shooting guns and talking about
there might be bloodshed if we don't fix our
election system. Of course, placating the same
believers of the big lie that actually did the
rioting on January 6th. When you put it together,
this is a very astute political ad because
it's not making the allegations wildly or
in an ad hominem sense or without context. It's
just showing. Look at this. And if we took that
video and those statements by Madison Cawthorn
and you change them and it was equivalent, but
a Muslim or even just a Democrat making similar
types of claims, which I mean, I can't imagine
whatever happened. They would be saying, shouldn't
the FBI be investigating this guy? And of course,
we've said many times actually, yeah, the FBI
should be investigating this guy. So a really,
really interesting ad by Jasmine
Beach Ferrare. It's great to see
that there are people challenging these wild,
outrageous people how well they'll do in
twenty, twenty two. We just don't know yet. It's
too early to say. But what we can say for sure is
if we are really going to like beat back Trump
ism and maybe even prevent Trump from running
in twenty, twenty four, it's going to depend on
removing some of these people from elected office
in November of twenty twenty two. Jasmine Beach,
Ferrare one possibility in Madison, Catherines
district. We'll have more time to cover her race
and many of these other ones as we go forward